So good afternoon class. Today we do
death by gerontocracy. Gerontocracy just
means rule by old people. Last class we
discussed the decline of western society
and civilization and why it's happening.
We discussed the theories. Today we will
look at what the reality on the ground
is. What the actual trends are. What are
the current examples of decline in the
western world. All right. So let me
start with this young man. Um his name
is Axel Ruda Kubana and he was 17 years
old when last year um he took a knife
and he walks into a dance studio in
Southport
uh Britain and then he proceeds to stab
the little girls inside the dance studio
and they are five, six, seven. He kills
three of them. He is quickly arrested by
the police. And as you can see, he is a
very disturbed young man. He clearly has
a mental illness. Otherwise, why would
he go kill children?
Um, and he was sentenced to 52 years
behind bars. So, he's going to spend the
rest of his life in prison. So, justice
was done.
What happens next is that all throughout
Britain there are riots and protests.
What happened was that rumors start to
spread online about the attack. They
claim that the young man was a asylum
seeker, an immigrant
and because there are too many
immigrants coming to England,
everyone's safety is at stake. So, as
you can see, these protests were
extremely heated. They were extremists.
Um, they were anti-immigrant and
ultimately it led to violence between
the police and the protesters.
And this is happening all throughout
Britain. Last summer, the country of
England burned basically,
literally burned. Okay, so these
protesters were setting cars on fire and
they were targeting immigrants in
Britain. Remember that this 17-year-old
boy, he's actually not an immigrant. He
was born in Wales to parents who are
from Rwanda. Okay. So, he is a um
British citizen.
As you can see,
the men who participated in the protest
um they're not sad about what they're
doing. They feel virtuous. They feel
righteous. They feel proud for
protecting their people against
immigrants.
So the question for us today is why is
this happening? Why are the all these
civil conflicts caused by immigration
throughout the western world? So this is
happening in Britain. But as you know
immigration United States led to the
victory of Donald Trump in last year's
elections in the United States.
A lot of the conflict comes from the
fact that immigration is happening too
fast in the western world. So after co
um you see this large spike in
immigrants. The other issue is that most
of these immigrants are coming from
um countries in the Middle East, in
Africa, in East Asia. So it's clear that
these people are different from you.
Okay. So before there might have been a
lot of EU, European immigrants, but now
it's just mainly countries outside of
Europe. So the British people feel as
though they're being invaded by
foreigners.
The changes, demographic changes to
British society are stark. So the uh I'm
not sure if you can see this clearly.
Okay. But like the dark brown are places
where in the past
5 10 years the immigrant population has
tripled has tripled three times. Okay.
And as you can see there are quite a few
pockets where immigr immigration is sort
of overwhelming the local population. So
if you go to Britain, there are some
places where you feel this is like
Morocco or this or this is like Rhonda
or maybe even uh Egypt. Okay. So the
British people feel they're under siege
and this happening throughout the
western world. So this is Australia.
Okay. So Australia after co huge spike
in immigration
and most of them are coming from
non-European countries. So the greatest
spike is in India but then you also have
China and the Philippines as well. These
are the three major sources of
immigrants to Australia. Okay.
The same is happening in France where
you're seeing a huge spike in
immigration and again most of the
immigrants are coming from African or
Middle Eastern countries and so the
French feel as though their culture is
being diluted. It's being attacked and
invaded.
This happening all throughout Western
Europe. The UK, France, Italy and
Germany are seeing a huge spike in
immigrants and refugees and so their
culture feels threatened.
What these what's also happening is a
huge spike in inflation. Okay, so this
is something called the CPI, the
consumer price index, which is just
measuring the price of basic goods
like food and shelter. Okay? And as you
can see, there's a huge spike in prices.
So, as these immigrants are coming into
your country, you also feel as though
your quality of life is getting worse
and worse. It's getting harder for you
to afford basic goods like rent and
food. it's getting harder for you to um
support your family.
The major increase is in housing prices.
Okay, so Canada these past 5 years has
seen a huge influx of immigrants and
this has caused housing prices to
skyrocket. The United States, which has
a much larger economy than Canada, the
housing prices are pretty stable. You
can still afford to buy a house if
you're a young person in United States,
not in Canada. Okay, you see this huge
spike in Canada. The house housing
prices are now unaffordable.
This is a chart that shows you economic
growth as compared to housing prices.
So, as you can see, United States um
housing prices there's a correlation
between income and housing prices. Okay,
this is pretty reasonable. In Canada, it
is not reasonable. Okay, so GDP is GDP,
housing prices is growing like this, but
housing prices is just skyrocketing
and that's why Canadians feel as though
the Canadian dream of one day having
their own house, it's basically dead.
So, one strange thing is that as Canada
lets in more immigrants,
um, and as property houses go up, you
would think that they would build more
and more houses, but as you can see,
housing supply, okay, housing supply,
it's pretty flat, even though
immigration is going up. Does anyone
know why this would be the case? Why is
it that you have a policy of letting in
more immigrants, but you don't have a
policy of building more housing for
them? That's kind of strange, right?
Does anyone can anyone guess why that
would be the case?
Yeah.
>> Sorry. Can you can you speak in the
microphone? Thank you.
>> Okay. Um maybe they
want to make sure that the housing's not
affordable maybe because they want to
make more money cuz now there's like
more competition for housing.
Definitely. As you said the prices of
housing was like going like skyrocketing
and people would make more money like
people who provide the housings would
naturally real estate's people make more
money I guess.
>> Yeah that's exact exactly correct. Okay.
So policy is not being controlled by
what's best for the nation and the
people. It's controlled by vested
interests that will make money off the
process. Right. So as you say real
estate developers can make money off
this process. But the people who who
benefit the most actually property
owners right. So you if you have a if
you already have a house
if the supply is constant but the demand
goes up then you know by from economic
class that the value of a house
increases artificially. So it's making
homeowners very happy.
Okay. And that's why you have this
crisis in Canada.
Um the other issue that's really
problematic in the western world is that
as immigrate as the number of immigrants
goes up,
native people, the native population,
they're not having children. Okay, so
this is this is Canada where the birth
rate, okay, the blue is the birth rate,
okay, it's steadily going down whereas
immigrants are going up. So it's the
immigrants who provide most of the new
people in Canada. In fact, right now,
25% a quarter of all Canadians are first
generation immigrants. Uh, sorry, first
generation Canadians, meaning that that
they they're immigrants to the country.
And if you just look at this trend, in
40 years time, 50 years time, there'll
be very few white Canadians in Canada.
And this is causing a lot of lot of
conflict and tension in the country.
So you have these huge issues. Um
housing is unaffordable, inflation is
going up,
ethnic tensions are increasing, but the
Canadian government still insists on
increasing the number of immigrants in
the country. Okay? There's no there's no
policy roll back where like you know
what, let's have a moratorum. Um,
clearly our policy is too rapid and we
need to slow things down. In fact, as
you can see, they're they're actually
going to ramp up the process. The goal
for Canada right now, Canop population
is about 35 to 40 million people. They
want 100 million people 100 million
people in Canada by the year 2100. And
guess what? The majority of these people
are going to come from India and
probably China.
Okay?
And as we discussed the percentage of
immigrants
as part of the total population is just
rapidly increasing. So in Australia it's
almost a third now. In Canada it's a
quarter. In Germany it's a fifth. And
these percentage will go up and up and
up leading to more and greater ethnic
tension and immigrant protests within
these countries.
As you can see, uh, the number of
immigrants coming from India far
surpasses that of other countries. Okay?
And these are just legal immigrants.
We're not counting in students. So,
there are millions and millions of
Indian students right now in Canada on
student visas and they're looking for a
path to permanent residency, to
citizenship. And that's what leads to
situations like this. Okay? these viral
videos online where you have thousands
and thousands of Indian students lining
up for hours and hours because they're
applying for a minimum wage job at a
restaurant or at a store. Life for these
Indian students is just terrible. A lot
of them live eight to a room. Okay, this
one room that was meant for one person.
There are now eight students living in
that room.
At the same time, what's really
interesting is that the Indians are now
a extremely powerful political force in
Canada. This was the former prime
minister Justin Trudeau meeting with
representatives of the Indian community
because he depends on them for his
votes.
In last year's federal election, 22
Indian
uh
people of Indian descent were elected to
parliament. Okay. So in parliament
there's 343 seats. 22 of them now are
Indian.
How many Chinese? How how many MPs of
Chinese origin? There are less than 10.
So even though the Chinese have been
there longer and even though they're
actually the more numerous Chinese than
Indians, the Indians are extremely
powerful political force. Now a lot of
it is because Indians um come from
democracy. So they're very good at
debate. They're very good at organizing.
They're very good at collective action.
And that's what let leads them to excel
in the Canadian political system. At the
same time, we can imagine that if
current trends continue, if the
immigrant population from India
increases
um and if the Indians continue to amass
more more political power, there could
be a situation where the Indians take
over the Canadian government in like 20
or 40 years time. So there's a real risk
that in Canada that their native
population gets replaced by the Indians.
And this is happening elsewhere as well.
Yes. A question.
>> Uh like the all the imi Indian
immigrants that you have mentioned like
it's took a part of the Canadian
population. How about the like uh having
the risk of aliens took over Canadian
but how about the people that is local
in Canadian like how are they doing
right now because we are all focusing on
immigrants
>> right okay that's a great question okay
so immigrants are suffering but actually
the local population is suffering even
more because as we discussed the last
class the economy is declining and it's
pretty rapid rapid decline. So, it's
harder for young people to find jobs,
especially with immigrants coming into
the country, right? Um prices are very
expensive nowadays. So, it's very hard
for young people to live and work in big
cities. So, as these immigrants are
coming into the country, they're putting
tremendous pressure on the local
population. That's why there's so much
ethnic tension uh throughout the Western
world right now. Okay. So this leads us
to a paradox.
If immigrants are making life worse for
everyone, especially young people, who's
the future of these nations, why is this
happening? Okay, so I want you guys to
keep this in the back of your mind. You
probably know the answer already because
you you you know how property prices
work, right? Okay, so uh let's move on
to another topic. So Canada like 10
years ago introduced a new policy called
maid called medical assistance in dying
euthanasia
and the idea here is that
if you feel life is meaningless if
you're depressed um if you feel that you
cannot cure your disease the government
will help you kill yourself. The
government will let you die. Now the big
question then is yeah but 25 years ago
this was illegal in the world right you
suicide was you was illegal if you
helped someone kill himself you'll be
put in prison this would be basically
murder.
So what's the difference between suicide
and the government helping you kill
yourself? Well there really isn't. Okay
but the government says there is a
difference. Okay. So this a brochure
from the government from the Can
government explaining you why suicide is
bad. Okay. Suicide is bad but suicide by
government is good. Okay. And it's
really stupid. It's disgusting. Stupid.
It's disgustingly stupid. Okay. What
they say is that if you if you do
suicide well you do it alone and you
shock your friends and family. But
if you do maid, then everyone knows
you're killing yourself and so they
won't be so sad when you die,
right? If you kill yourself,
you might screw it up, but if the
government does it for you, you won't
screw it up because it's it's being uh
facilitated by professionals who know
what they're doing.
All right? If you think this is stupid,
there's more stupidity to come. Right?
And what this tells us is we discussed
this last class is one major sign of
decline in society is the over
bureaucratization of society with the
government interferes in everything.
Okay.
Um this is the number actually number of
deaths
from euthanasia in Canada. As you can
see in 2016, it started at about a
thousand. By 2021, it's at 10,000. Okay?
So, the numbers are going up really
rapidly.
Why? Well, because if you want to kill
yourself, they won't stop you. This is
the number of days required
to be approved for suicide. As you can
see in the Netherlands, sorry, this is
Oregon, actually. This is Oregon, United
States. Okay. The number of days have
been going down, but it's still like at
most a month. Okay. In Canada, they'll
do it in like 10 days for you.
They won't even think about it. They're
like, "You want to kill yourself? Do it,
man. Good for you. Good choice."
Doctors have been trained
to not do any harm, right?
Well, and death ought to be the last
resort. But in Canada, death is now the
first resort. If you go to a doctor and
say, "I want to die." The doctor's like,
"Sure, let's do it, man." That's pretty
disgusting.
All right. Why are people people
killing? So, like, if you see um the
number of approval rates have been going
way up. It seems that it seems as though
they have a quarter of the field. This
is 2019.
Um only 7 75% were approved. Now, it's
81%. It's almost like they have a quota.
They're trying to kill as many people as
possible, right?
Um, as you can see, this number is the
percentage of people who die because of
euthanasia. Uh, this is the Netherlands,
which for the longest time had a very
open policy when it comes to euthanasia.
And yeah, it's going up, but this huge
spike is Canada. Okay. It seems as
though Canada can is in a rush to kill
as many people as possible. So who's
dying?
>> Yeah. Do you have do you have a
question?
>> So the suicide of Canada is not insunia.
Is that also a type of in insunasia?
>> No. No. No. Okay. All right. So suicide
is when you kill yourself. Euphanasia is
when a doctor helps you kill yourself.
Euphania means good death.
It means like you will die painlessly.
Okay.
>> No, no, no. Okay. Euphania is suicide by
government.
Okay. All right. So, why are people
dying? Well, a lot as you can see most
is actually from cancer. Now, what's
interesting about cancer is that it's
the most expensive disease to treat,
right? Well, that's interesting.
And a lot of cancer, it's not um it's
not it's pretty painful, but it's not
terminal. You can still live with
cancer, right? So, it seems as though um
people with cancer are being encouraged
to die because they're a burden on the
system. Which means who's dying? Who's
dying here? It's poor people who are
dying, right? That's this is pretty
obvious.
And this is even more interesting. Okay,
this is the most disgusting part.
If the government were to prove your
death, you would think that there would
be a rigorous process, right? It would
be the last option. But let's understand
why people are killing themselves. And
the two main reasons. The first major
reason is loss of ability to engage in
meaningful activities. It's because
you're not happy.
This is a lame reason to kill yourself.
Okay.
Also, loss of ability to perform
activities of daily living.
It's harder for you to go buy groceries.
It's harder for you to walk around.
Okay. So, again, what's happening is
that poor people are dying and poor
people are encouraged to kill themselves
because the poor are being a burden on
the medical system. And that's the
entire basis of euthanasia. So let me
ask you this question.
Why is it that 25 years ago we
discouraged euthanasia? In fact we legal
to conduct euthanasia even if the person
was suffering from brain cancer and the
person was just basically in hell every
day. The government would not allow
euthanasia. Why not?
>> Yeah.
>> Maybe because it was like harder to
regulate like the procedures to take for
youth in Asia and because it was like
such a new thing, you have no control
over what the companies who like provide
the service do. Yeah.
>> Or like what they do to their um
patients. I wouldn't even say patients
but like people who purchase their
services and also um all because again
it's such a novel thing um the
procedures involved the medical
companies involved maybe um what maybe
to me loopholes and it was if I was the
government I'd consider that as a
potential danger something that may be
dis like disturbing to this current
system.
>> Okay. All right. Yeah that's a very
interesting answer. Okay. What it tells
me is that the the society you live in
is very different from the society I
grew up in. Okay? Because 25 years ago
when when I was younger, we were taught
that every life matters. Every life is a
gift from God. And as society, we have
to protect everyone, especially the
poor, the vulnerable, and the
marginalized because that's how we come
together as a society. If we just let
anyone die, then how do you know that
you'll be protected?
Right? So what mattered back then was
about social cohesion, social capital,
social trust. And now what matters is
just numbers. How much does this cost
me? How much revenue will this generate?
Okay, so that's the difference in the
world today. Before we cared about
social cohesion, we care about morality.
Nowadays it's all just money, money,
money.
Um, and this is interesting for us.
Okay, another sign of decline is growing
financialization. We talked about this
last class, right? Well, guess what's
happening in the stock markets
throughout the world? It's booming.
Okay, it's booming. If you're a rich
person, you're just getting richer and
richer. 10% of the population owns 9% of
the stocks in America. Okay, so this is
an indicator of how wealthy the rich
have become in the past 20 years. In the
year 2008,
um if you bought Amazon, you would buy
for $7. Now it's like $300. Okay? So
that just shows you how wealthy the rich
have become due to government policies.
At the same time, we talked about this
last class, productivity,
real economy, the amount of work you you
do, it's going way down. So we have we
have this absurd situation where the
fake economy, the financial economy is
going way up, but the real economy of
jobs, of people doing work, of being
productive, it's going way down.
Okay? Meaning that we live in a fake
world.
And the government responds by lying to
people. Okay? People know their lives
suck. People know that basically the
economy is in a recession.
That's what the facts say. But the
government But and what does the
government do? Well, the government says
that oh, it's not really recession. What
it really is is a state of trans
transition. Okay, this this is what we
call gaslighting.
This is blending gaslighting. Rather
than just say, you know what, the
economy is in trouble and we feel your
pain and we're going to work hard to
solve the problem. They're telling you,
"No, no, no. It's not black. It's white,
guys. You You're lying. Your eyes,
they're lying to you. Don't you see?
You're not seeing clearly. Get new
glasses and you your life will be a lot
better." That's like literally what
they're telling you. Um, debt, right? We
talked about this last class as well.
This is US debt. You can see how the
debt is booming. Okay? So, up in the
year until the year 1980 for 200 years,
America's existence, there was very
little debt. Now
look at this. Okay, America right now is
$37 trillion in debt. That's a
government. Okay, the people with their
credit card debt, with their mortgages,
they owe $17 trillion. They'll never pay
that off. So basically, the middle class
in America, it's finished. Okay, the
government has no more resources.
This is what decline looks like.
Um, no one's having children anymore.
Okay, so the world sucks and young
people are like, "Screw this. I'm not
having kids." Okay, this is happening
throughout the world.
Canada is selling its resources to
outside investors. Okay, so oil is a big
Canadian resource. As you can see, a lot
of the big players in Canada are
actually American or overseas. When it
says Canada, it's you it usually means
British people. So Canadians don't even
own their own resources anymore.
So let's summarize what we've learned
today. Okay, let's look at the signs of
Western decline. You got higher property
prices. This happened throughout the
Western world. Inflation and lower
quality of life, higher stock market
valuations, which means greater
inequality.
Less real economic growth, less and less
people are doing real jobs. Euthan Asia
for the poor just killing off the poor
people. Mass immigration, population
replacement, lower birth rate, greater
public and private debt, bureaucratic
gaslighting where the government no
longer acknowledges problems. It just
lies to you directly and privatization,
asset stripping. Okay, so all this is
happening in the Western world. The
question now is why would this happen?
And there are different theories. Okay?
And
uh we'll go over some of the major
theories. There's lots and lots of
theories. We'll go over the major ones.
And there's going to be overlap between
these theories. And um some of these
theories make a lot of sense. Okay. So
one major theory is idea of
neoliberalism. The idea of neoliberalism
is the belief that all that matters in
society, all that matters in life is
economic growth. If you if your society
can generate more economic growth, all
problems will be solved. Okay. So, so if
your economy runs really fast then
everyone will be happy. That's the idea
of neoliberalism. Then you have
technofudalism which is the idea that
some big corporations usually these tech
companies they want to control the world
and so they want to turn everyone into
slaves and if you don't have a house if
you don't have your own property then
you can you can be controlled by these
companies. Okay. technofudalism
uh world government where the United
Nations has a has this conspiracy to
control the entire world to distort
national sovereignty and create a world
unified government. Okay. Uh population
replacement theory and the idea here is
that the problem for governments in the
western world is that white people are
opinionated. They believe in democracy.
They believe in freedom and they're hard
to control. So, let's replace the white
people with Chinese and Indians and
Filipinos because Asian people are more
obedient, right? That's the idea. And
again, uh these are just theories. I'm
not saying they're right or wrong. Okay?
And we'll go into these theories later
on semester. Now, the last reason is
bureaucratic incompetence. Just the
government is just stupid. Okay? Now
there is overlap among these theories
and there's some validity to all these
theories but what I want to show you is
that there's actually a much better way
to analyze this. Whenever you have a
problem, you always ask yourself who
benefits,
who is benefiting from this, right? So,
when we're talking about housing prices,
well, clearly property owners are
benefiting from this, right? So, if we
took all the groups, okay, and there's
like millions and millions of different
groups in society. We just analyze who
benefits from all these trends that we
discussed, the answer you would get is
rich pensioners.
These are the people who benefit the
most from these trends and therefore we
can suspect that they're the ones behind
these trends. Okay, so let's go over
them. Property prices make sense, right?
Because they're old. They have houses.
They probably have two or three houses.
So they want to see the property prices
go up. Higher start market valuations
makes sense because they own the most
stocks. Youthation for the poor makes
sense because they want good medical
care. If poor people are standing in
line, that's a problem for them, right?
So just kill the poor people and and
they'll have better access to healthare,
right? If that frees up the healthare
system. Mass immigration means cheap
labor. If they're old, they're 70 or 80
years old. They need gardeners. They
need cooks.
They need nurses,
right? Immigrants. Are you guys going do
you guys want to be gardeners and cooks
and
uh laborers? You don't want want to be.
So we have to be in immigrants
and everything else. Okay. inflation, em
growth, lower birth rate, gaslighting,
it doesn't really affect them. Does that
make sense? So all these trends, some of
them are really good for these
pensioners and the rest doesn't really
affect the pensioners and that's why we
we can assume for analysis that's the
rich pensioners who are most responsible
for what's going on.
Does does it make sense to you guys? All
right. So, how how can we understand
this? Well, the problem that we're
facing is never in human history have we
had so many old rich people before.
Okay? And you can see these trends where
in the year 1900,
people who are 75 and older were just a
small fraction of society. But you can
see how fast they're growing. Okay? 60
over 60 years old, really growing really
fast. There's a problem because if they
keep on if they keep on living they
accumulate more and more resources
which creates a lot more inequality.
Now I'm not saying that all old people
are rich. In fact that's not the case.
If you just look at statistics you will
find that wealth is pretty much evenly
disputed distributed among demographics.
Okay? So there are young people with a
lot of money but there are more old
people with money. Okay? So there and
there are lots and lots of old people.
the purple or old people who are poor.
I'm I'm not saying that old people are
the problem. I'm saying that old rich
people are the problem.
They're problem because they want their
pensions.
The pension systems in all societies
made assumptions about old people. The
major assumption that they made is that
old people would die. Right? So, for
example, in Canada, uh, when they first
create the pension system, the
retirement age was 65 and they expected
people to die when they were 72. So, you
have five to seven years of a good
pension. Okay? Guess what, guys? They're
not dying, right? And that creates a
huge problem with your pension plan. And
you can see how these liabilities are
going up over time.
uh these are teachers and and as you can
see the liabilities are going way up.
Why is this happening? It's happening
because of something called assumption
changes. Okay, so two assumptions are
being made. First is that OP will die.
Well, they're not dying. The other
assumption is that if you put money in
the stock market, it will o it will
yearbyear
improve, right? The problem is that
there's volatility in the stock market.
It goes up and goes down.
And the smart people make money off dumb
people.
Guess what guys? Okay, I'm going to ask
you a question. In finance, where do the
dumbest people work? You guys know in
finance, the dumbest people work where
they work in pension funds. Why? Because
it's a boring job. You just sit there
and do nothing all day. So these pension
funds are constantly getting ripped off
from investment banks where the smart
people are. Okay. So if you look at all
investment vehicles, pension funds have
lost the most money and this has created
huge issues
within government pension funds
throughout the world.
Okay. So as you can see there's
volatility in returns in the pension
fund. Okay. when you put the money in,
the returns will differ year by year,
and that screws up your model.
If you're a young person, do not put
money in the pension fund. Why? Because
the value of the pension fund is going
drastically down.
When you grow up, when you mature, and
you retire, guess what, guys? There's no
money in the pension fund for you
because all that money is gone. Why?
Because there are too many retirees and
not enough workers. All right. So back
in the year 2001, you had a problem. You
had 7.6
uh retirees for every 12.7 workers. This
is you basically the ideal is 1 to
three. So one pensioner, three workers.
That's a healthy pension system. Now you
have more pensioners, okay, than you
have workers. This is a huge problem.
These pensions will all go bankrupt in 5
to 10 years time.
At the same time, as I said, old people
are not dying. In fact, old people are
coming to dominate society. This is
America. You can see how people are who
are 85 and older. Whoa. Look at this.
Look at this.
The aging crisis in America is huge. But
this is it's not just America. It's
everywhere.
Right?
So by the year 20 240 you have 65
million people in America who are over
65. You have 15 million Americans who
are 85. And guess what? These 15
Americans most of them are the ones who
control America. So they dictate policy
and again this is happening throughout
the world. Okay. It's particularly stark
in Japan and Germany but this is
happening throughout the world.
And this leads us to the idea of
gerontocracy. Okay, this is Joe Biden,
president of the United States, and this
is Mitch McConnell who was head of the
Senate. Uh they're both retired now.
Okay, but they're both in their 80s and
they were the two most powerful men in
America. He can't walk straight. Okay,
whenever he walks, he trips. This guy is
even worse because look at this. The
guy's brain dead.
The guy is literally brain dead in
public. Okay, he be like
and like no matter what you do, he's
like
this is brain dead. Okay, the guy's this
is a brain freeze. The guy should not be
one of the most powerful men in America,
but he is. That's the world we live in
because he will not give up power.
This is Dian Feinstein. She died in
office. She was 90 years old.
She was 90 years old and she was still
working and she died in her office and
she was a senator in the United States.
These people are literally
fighting for life. Okay? They refuse to
give up power. You they only give up
power if they die.
This is the US Senate. Again, the most
powerful political institution in
America. These are people who are above
the standard retirement age which is
662. Okay, this guy's 90 years old and
he's still working. 90 years old and
he's still working in the Senate and he
doesn't want to retire. Chuck Grassley.
What does it mean to have a world run by
old people? Now maybe in school, maybe
you've been t maybe at home you've been
taught that old people are wise. They're
tolerant. They're generous. They're
benevolent. No, no, no, guys. No. The
difference between these three
generations, young, mature, and elderly,
are pretty stark. If you're young,
you're rebellous. You want to change the
system. If you're mature, you want
things to move slowly. Okay? But if
you're elderly, you're reactionary,
means meaning you don't want anything to
change.
Okay? If you change anything, they get
upset and slap you. That's reactionary.
Young people are creative. Mature people
want growth. But elder people care first
and foremost about safety.
Uh young people are open-minded. Mature
people want consensus mean they want
everyone to get along. But other people
are stubborn. They want things their
way.
So
we are now living in a joury which is
ruled by elderly people. Okay? So we're
going to live in a reactionary stubborn
system only concerned about the safety
of these people. And so what does that
mean?
Well, it means that
the world will go into lockdown. When
when there's a virus, guess what? We're
all we're going to have to shut down
because old people are afraid of
catching germs.
It will also lead to a police state.
Okay? Now, police state does not mean
that there'll be terrible police coming
to beat us up. In fact, you know, if in
real life, most police that you meet are
really, really nice people. But um
you'll have no individual freedom. Okay.
So let let me give you an example of
this. So in Canada um a Chinese moved to
Canada and uh she bought a house and her
son is very naughty
and her son was so naughty that she
wants to slap him. But she she knows
that in Canada you can't really slap
children even in private, right? So she
goes on online and asks everyone, "Can I
slap my child?" And everyone's like,
"You can't do that because if you do
that, your neighbor should report you to
the police." But what you can do is
report your child to the police. Tell
the police your child is naughty and
they'll come and help you discipline
your child. In fact, you can get you can
come get the police to come every single
week. They like that. This is what we
call a police state. Okay? Intrusive
government interference into your
personal lives.
Oh, and lots of lots of surveillance.
Okay. Wherever you move, you'll be
tracked. Whatever call you make, you'll
be tracked.
Um, in 2003,
Britain passed something called the
online safety act. And the idea is if
you say anything bad online, you can get
arrested. Okay? So, the freedom of
expression is being limited. This passed
in 2022 23 in Britain, but I assume it
will pass everywhere in the western
world.
Digital currency. The idea of digital
currency is the idea of financial
repression. So they're trying to
eliminate cash because with cash is
freedom. You you can do what whatever
you want with cash. You can buy whatever
you want for how much you want with
cash. But with digital currency, all
your transactions will be limited and
monitored. Okay? So in the future you
will not be able to buy video games
because that's bad for you.
Oh microchip implants guys right? Isn't
that great? You before you had cell
phones then you had facial recognition
and in the future you have implants
microchip implants.
Immigrants lots and lots of immigrants
because poor people sorry rich
pensioners need help. They need nurses.
They need laborers. They need gardeners.
They need people to mow their lawn. So
you have massive immigration coming into
the country.
Oh, but good news, okay? It'll be easier
for you to study in America from now on,
right? Today, Trump announced he wants
600,000 Chinese students to go to the
United States. Right? Before you guys
were worried about not getting your
visas and uh getting denied at the
border, don't worry, guys. They want you
to go to the United States because you
guys are the best labor. Okay? You're
cheap, you're obedient, and you're
studious, and you're young.
Okay? So, this is the plan to let in
more Chinese students into America so
you guys can take care of elderly
people. Isn't that great? Good news,
right?
Oh, lots and lots of prisons, guys.
Okay? Because elder people are afraid of
criminals. And also prisoners are free
labor. Isn't that great?
Oh, and one more thing. War after war
after war.
All right. This is what it means by
death by gerontocracy. This is what it
means to live in a world governed by
elderly people.
Elderly people are perfectly happy to
send young people to die for their
glory.
All right. Okay. Pretty depressing, but
don't worry, things will get even more
depressing as we go along. All right.
All right. Good. Any questions?
Are you guys clear? Any questions?
Yeah.
like for like the above that you said
that elders controls the society and
wants like they exploit young people but
is there a way that young people could
like overthrown or having method to
solve this?
>> Yeah, that's actually a great question.
So what can young people do about this?
And the answer is nothing. Okay. And the
reason why and this is really really
important is that young people are
biologically ingrained to respect the
elders, right? This this is true
throughout nature. Even young animals
will respect their elders.
So, do you want to go kill your
grandparents? Probably not. Okay. So,
there's nothing anyone can do about
this. This is just the unfortunate state
of affairs. Okay. Old people are people
we are biologically
trained or wired to respect and obey.
That's why they can send us to wars and
we'll go fight wars.
Okay. Does that make sense? All right.
Yeah.
>> So, what happened after the rich pension
elders dead?
Like what about their money?
>> Okay. All right. That's a good question.
Okay. So, as you can see from these
charts, eventually there'll be a pension
crisis where there are too many
pensioners, enough money. Well, guess
what? The old people are the major
political force in society. They dictate
policy. So what will happen is that
money will be diverted from elsewhere
into pensions where schooling, right?
Public schooling, uh health care, um
everywhere basically. Okay. But that but
the pensioners will want that money. And
pensioners first of all, they're
powerful, but they also have a lot of
free time on their hands to make trouble
for everyone. And also because we
respect our el the elderly, right? Okay.
Do you want to deny health care and
pension to your grandparents?
So everyone will be for this. There's
nothing we can do about it,
right? Good question.
But like people humans life have a limit
like what will happen after like they
all died because they are just
uh although they are elders and those
reach pensions they are still
generations of human. That's a really
great point. Okay. So the idea is that
what happens when they die off? Well
they're not dying off. Okay. They were
supposed to die at 72. Now they're
living to like a 100. Modern medicine is
incredible. I have I have a friend who's
like 90 years old. She's like literally
brain dead. Okay, she's like literally
brain dead. She's 90 years old, but
she's filthy rich and she has access to
the best health care. So, I asked my
friend uh who's a doctor like if you're
filthy rich and you want to keep on
living, how long could modern medicine
keep you keep you going on even though
you're vegetable? And they and he said
to me, 20 years. 20 years. 20 years of
being a vegetable but she has money so
and she wants to keep on living then she
can do that. Okay.
And that was not available before
because of scarcity right because of
lack of technology. But nowadays
because of abundance because of
technology
um opio can live as long as they want
to. And also this what this chart tells
us that when the green goes away the red
becomes the green right? So you'll
always have a society where the elderly
are in control.
Okay? Does that make sense? Unless of
course there were maybe I don't know a
catastrophe, a nuclear holocaust, who
knows? Okay. But but yeah, but given the
way things are, the trend is that old
people can control society for a long
time because if there's a war, it's not
old people who die, it's young people
who die.
Okay. But but good question. Okay. Uh
any more questions?
Okay, great. So, um we'll continue this
next class. Okay, thank you.